A member of the US army steps up to the counter.
Hey, don't deal with this guy.
He's Muslim.
Is he laughing?
Why is that funny?
Hold on, what happened?
This guy is a Muslim.
We live in America.
He can have any religion he wants.
Aren't you fighting against these guys?
Not at the moment.
Right now, I'm ordering a sandwich.
I don't think you should be working here.
Buy your chips and move out.
He doesn't follow orders.
Look, I'd like to order some food, just not from you, okay?
Get out!
Put the chips down and go buy them somewhere else.
You want me to leave this place?
You have a choice to shop anywhere...
...just like he has a choice to practice his religion anywhere.
That's the reason I wear the uniform,...
...so anyone can live free in this country.
Leave the man alone, buy your stuff and leave.
People might say that's very heroic, what you said.
Is it?
No, sir.
No, heroes come in many shapes and sizes.
That wasn't heroic at all.
I was just being a person and standing up for someone else.
But what principles were you defending?
Everyone's unalienable rights.
Everyone's?
Everyone's in this country.
You're Muslim?
It doesn't matter to me, sir.
If you're American, you're an American, period.